en este ejercicio nos preguntan cuál de
las siguientes funciones tiene esta
serie de taylor en cero por lo que es
una muy buena idea empezar pensando
acerca de esta serie veamos cuando en es
igual a cero menos uno elevado a la
potencia cero es un 1 x elevada a la
potencia 0 también es 1 y 0 factoriales
1 así es que esta serie empieza con un 1
más
este término cuando n es igual a 1 pero
cuando n es igual a 1 aquí vamos a tener
un signo negativo por lo que ya no
tenemos más tenemos menos y luego
tenemos x elevado a la potencia 1 / 1
factorial o sea x / 1 pero esto lo
podemos escribir simplemente como x y
luego cuando n es igual a 2 tenemos aquí
menos 1 al cuadrado
así es que aquí tenemos un 1 vamos
sumar este término x elevada a la 2
entre 2 factorial y luego tenemos menos
x al cubo entre 3 factorial más x a la 4
entre 4 factorial y esto va a seguir
alternando se más menos más menos y así
y ahora nuestra fórmula general para una
serie de taylor en 0 también conocida
como la serie de mac loring la fórmula
general es así primero tenemos
efe de 0 luego tenemos que sumar la
derivada de f en 0 por x más la segunda
derivada de f en 0 por x al cuadrado
entre 2 más
la tercera derivada de f en 0 por x
elevado a la 3 entre 3 factorial más la
cuarta derivada de f en 0 por x a la 4
entre 4 factorial y bueno tenemos aquí
la idea de cómo sigue esto porque
tenemos que seguir sumando y sumando
todos los términos de la serie ahora
nosotros lo que queremos es encontrar
cuál de estas funciones tiene esta serie
de taylor en cero pero para que esto sea
la serie de taylor en cero para que sea
la serie de mclaren que por cierto esto
es lo que escribimos aquí en azul para
que esto sea la serie de mack loring de
alguna función este término tiene que
ser igual a éste
y luego este otro término también tiene
que ser igual a este pero vamos por
partes vamos a escribirlo con esto
sabemos que f de 0 tiene que ser igual a
1 y luego estos dos términos nos dicen
que f prima en 0 tiene que ser igual al
coeficiente de este término o sea menos
1 y luego por acá tenemos que f di prima
en 0 tiene que ser igual al coeficiente
de x al cuadrado entre 2 en este término
pero eso es simplemente un 1 y
seguramente aquí ya podemos ver la idea
general por ejemplo también sabemos que
la tercera derivada en 0 tiene que ser
igual al coeficiente de x al cubo entre
3 factorial osea menos 1 y ahora lo que
nos vamos a preguntar es si con esta
información que tenemos aquí ya sabemos
de estas funciones es la que tiene a
esta serie como serie de taylor en cero
aquí se puede hacer un poco de
razonamiento deductivo por ejemplo
podemos empezar evaluando todas estas
funciones en cero y viendo cuáles de
ellas son iguales a 1 cuando las
evaluamos en cero veamos vamos con este
ejemplo por aquí cuando evaluamos a 0 en
0 nos queda 0 entonces como ya sabemos
que f de 0 tiene que ser igual a 1 esto
directamente elimina a seno de x luego
coseno de 0 es 1
así es que la respuesta correcta todavía
podría ser coseno elevado a la 0 también
es 1 y por acá
elevado a la 0 es 1 y por aquí logaritmo
natural de 10
esto es logaritmo natural de 1 lo cual
es cero
así es que también lo podemos tachar con
esta única condición de que f de 0 tiene
que ser igual a 1 ya logramos eliminar a
dos de las opciones ahora tomemos en
cuenta esto que ya sabemos de que la
primera derivada en cero tiene que ser
igual a menos uno veamos cuál es la
primera derivada de coseno de x bueno
pues es menos seno de x si evaluamos
menos seno de x en 0 no vamos a obtener
menos 1 vamos a obtener 0
así es que podemos tachar este de una
vez ahora que a la x la primera derivada
de a la x es a la x y si le evaluamos en
0 vamos a obtener 1 no menos 1
así es que también podemos tachar esta
opción y ahora viendo las cosas como
están
podemos estar bastante seguros de que d
es la opción correcta pero vamos a
verificarlo la primera derivada
efe prima en x es igual a menos
a la menos x así es que la primera
derivada en 0 es igual a menos
a la 0 que es 1 entonces era la menos x
por lo menos cumple esta condición
y bueno si tienes un poco de curiosidad
podrías seguir verificando esto podría
checar que el ala menos x si cumple con
estas otras condiciones ahora lo que ya
sabemos es que la opción de es la única
de todas las opciones posibles en este
ejercicio que cumple con las primeras
dos condiciones la función evaluada en
cero y la primera derivada evaluada en
cero